super productions internationales
créations originales canal+ bienvenue à
versailles
il était une fois le roi un roi dont la
grandeur et la gloire était sans égal
le jeune louis xiv à l'aube de sa
splendeur
il est temps de leur montrer qui tu es
vraiment je sais qui je suis un roi
visionnaire comme vous ne l'avez jamais
vu c'est ici que nous devons bâtir notre
destin faire naître une nouvelle france
un univers flamboyant et rock'n'roll
devons mettre un pain à la construction
de versailles leur poids par enquête on
se sent au chaud quand le soleil brille
mais croyez moi dès qu'il en aura fini
avec vous toutes les lumières
versailles la syrie lundi 16 novembre
sur canal+